I think most people have a happy
Halloween no Halloween for the president
though did you hear this
President Obama canceled the Halloween
party at the White House
yeah Obama canceled after hearing Joe
Biden was coming as [ __ ] Joe Biden
I can't think of anything I'd rather
less see than [ __ ] Java it's it gets
everything all pushed up and yeah that
guy's got a rack
everyone cart you have carved your
pumpkins you gotten that taken care of a
company you might find this interesting
a company has come out with a kit that's
brand new that helps you carve
pornographic images into a pumpkin
pornographic images into a pumpkin yeah
the kit is being marketed under the name
the Amish Internet that's how those guys
do it
[Applause]
Jacob Jacob I found this pumpkin eater
I'm sorry father it's being reported
that although Hurricane sandy damaged
thousands of homes in New Jersey the
house used on Jersey Shore was left
completely undamaged
in other words there is no God
I think that's proof that's all you need
crazy story the lapis is real the laptop
used by Bill Clinton while he was
president is up for sale yeah just a tip
you might want to clean it first there
as you would with any use product you
[Applause]
and he's a perv no I mean well they cut
to me because I thought you said Andy I
thought you were a perv yeah you said
and he's a perv but they thought you
said Andy supply
[Applause]
all I know is when I was mentioning the
pornographic pumpkin kid I say going
like this there are rumors that the wife
of North Korean dictator Kim jong-un is
pregnant so finally a successful missile
launch from North Korea
[Applause]
due to the tough economy two of the
world's biggest publishing houses have
decided to merge and become one yeah to
the biggest publishing houses are
merging
in fact they're only going to publish
one book this year Fifty Shades of Harry
Potter we have up can we have a little
pervy pervy Voldemort maybe I'm going to
spank you with your Wang now I'd like
you to meet Nagini it's my favorite
impression Kelsey Grammer said that he
brought his three-month-old daughter to
a party at the Playboy Mansion because
he couldn't find a good babysitter yeah
then again most of kelsey Grammer's
marriages ended because he did find a
good babysitter
[Applause]
judging it a bit and I like